this morning Cokie Roberts many admirers
say she helped transform the role of
women in broadcast news yes she did
Roberts whose parents were both members
of Congress covered Washington politics
for 40 years she died yesterday at the
age of 75 of complications from breast
cancer 60 minutes correspondent Lesley
Stahl remembers her trailblazing friend
and the most important thing that
Roberts told her about reporting
journalism has lost one of the greats a
real seeker of truth but for me losing
Cokie Roberts is like losing the best
sister anyone ever had and there are a
whole lot of other women journalists who
are feeling exactly the same way what
you're hearing a lot of out there in the
electorate is the women can't do a worse
job than these guys we were in a ladies
lunch group together in Washington back
in the 1970s when there were so few
women covering politics that all of us
fit around one small table Cokie was the
one with wisdom the one we all went to
for advice mostly though we talked about
girl things because the conversations in
our offices were about sports and sports
at National Public Radio back then she
distinguished herself as a Capitol Hill
correspondent and help put NPR on the
map and then she went to ABC Cokie
Roberts where she was the voice of
clarity and depth as an analyst and
while doing that she became a
best-selling author of American history
there's a huge change in the years that
that I've been plowing this turf she
said that the best way to learn about a
period of time was to read the Diaries
and letters of the wives of the great
men because when the men wrote they
wrote for posterity but the women were
telling each other the truth I so
admired her work but she was at her very
best as a friend she persuaded me to
have a child by proving that you could
be an attentive mother as she was and
have a big career and then she helped me
raise my daughter the most important
thing she
ever said to me about being a journalist
and it's something I carry with me is do
no harm
Cokie Roberts was very kind
that's a lovely beautiful tribute Lesley
Stahl I once heard her say that as great
as this job is it's certainly not more
important than your family and I think
sometimes we need to be reminded of that
and we certainly do need to be reminded
of do no harm that could apply to many
things in life yeah I want to note the
passing of another giant of TV news
where's sander van ochre who who worked
at NBC and ABC it was actually the last
surviving member of the for journalists
panel that questioned Kennedy and Nixon
in that first television debate he was
also part of what they called the four
horsemen at NBC who used to prowl the
floors of the conventions it was John
Chancellor at Frank McGee Edwin Newman
and sander van ocher and he was also
when he went to ABC was the moderator
for the vice presidential debate between
Geraldine with Geraldine Ferraro and in
George HW Bush I remember them both as
they said you know two of the Great's
yeah there weren't examples for